-Right-wing conspiracy theories
about Russia's invasion
of Ukraine
have spun wildly out of control,
as Donald Trump,
leader of the Republican Party,
declared that,
if he were president,
he would threaten to use nukes
against Russia.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
We're all familiar
with the alternate universe
of lies and conspiracy theories
Republicans have spread
about the 2020 election.
Trump's gang of weirdos
keeps popping up
to repeat those lines
every chance they get.
Over the weekend,
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
was wandering around the grounds
at a Trump rally
in South Carolina,
rattling off a list of states
Trump had supposedly won,
but were stolen from him
because of voter fraud.
-You know where the most votes
in the United States
were stolen?
Anyone want to guess?
-Texas?
-California.
1.5 million votes were stolen
from Donald Trump.
Donald Trump won --
You want to hear
what states we know he won?
Here's the states
that Donald Trump won for sure.
He won Minnesota, Wisconsin,
Michigan, Pennsylvania,
New Hampshire, Georgia.
No. Georgia, Arizona,
and Nevada.
He probably -- We don't know,
but he might've won Maine.
He might've won Colorado.
There's four others in question.
-Are there any states
Trump didn't win?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Lindell ]
He won Wisconsin, Minnesota,
Pennsyldonia, Old Jersey,
New Jack City,
Arrakis, Endor, Xanadu,
and the one that has
the flag with
da bear.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, dude, if you're going
to ask people
to guess something, give them
a second to answer, first.
[ Laughter ]
The guy didn't get
the microphone back to his mouth
before you yelled it out.
Guess which hand
has the jelly bean.
It was this one, but I also
have one in this one.
Oh, wait, it's gone.
Somebody stole it!
No, wait.
I remember I ate it.
[ Laughter ]
But this fringe,
paranoid thinking is not unique
to the 2020 election.
As we've discovered
during Russia's horrific
invasion of Ukraine,
right-wing pundits have become
increasingly unhinged
in their conspiracy theories
about the war
and Biden's response.
Over the weekend,
Fox host Maria Bartiromo,
one of the most pro-Trump
voices on TV,
suggested that it was Joe Biden
who saw Vladimir Putin
as a partner
and didn't want to confront him.
-Some people have told me,
over the weekend,
that they feel that,
at the end of the day,
this administration
does not see Putin as the enemy.
They see him as a partner,
on many issues.
They see him as a partner
on climate change.
They see him
as a partner on the Iran deal.
When is this administration
going to get serious
in telling Vladimir Putin,
"We are done with partnerships"?
That means no Iran deal,
walk away,
no more renegotiating
on America's behalf,
no more products from Russia!
-No more products?!
We've already banned
Russian oil, vodka,
diamonds, and seafood.
I mean, what else is there?
[ As Bartiromo ]
No more products from Russia!
No more Russian ballet,
no more Russian salad dressing,
and no more of those
little Russian dolls!
[ Laughter ]
Biden keeps saying
he's going to ban them,
but then,
every time you open one up,
there's another one inside.
When?
When does it end, Joe?!
[ Laughter ]
Let's just go back
to this part for a minute.
-Some people have told me,
over the weekend --
-Alright, that sentence
right there is how you know
you're about to hear
some [bleep]
[ Laughter and applause ]
First of all,
you're kicking things off
with some unsourced
weekend gossip?
That's how my writers start off
their Monday morning excuses.
"Some people, over the weekend,
told me that,
if you smash two edibles
together, they, um,
cancel each other out.
[ Laughter ]
But I think they were wrong
and that's why I'm late
and all my clothes are wet
and -- Wait.
These aren't my clothes.
[ Laughter ]
What on Earth
are you talking about?
You think Biden sees Putin
as a partner?
First of all,
Trump is the one who called
Putin's invasion of Ukraine
savvy and genius
and desperately lavishes praise
on Putin every chance he gets.
Trump was clearly the one
who saw Putin as a partner,
although, I'm not sure Putin
felt the same way.
Based on Putin's face
when they were together,
Putin saw Trump as a competitor
who was way too easy
to outsmart.
[ Laughter ]
Putin always had the smile
of a spelling bee contestant
after the other kid
got a super hard word.
[ Laughter ]
"Your word is insouciant,"
[ As Trump ]
Insouciant? We love --
We love insouciant,
don't we, people?
[ Laughter ]
We love it.
It's a great word.
We love it
because it starts with an "I."
We know that.
[ Laughter ]
And then, right after that
comes the "N"
and, at that point,
at that point,
you've basically spelled it.
[ Laughter ]
You've bas--
And isn't that enough?
I feel like can we just leave it
there and get full credit?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
And they can't even seem
to keep their conspiracy
theory straight.
One day, Biden, supposedly,
sees Putin as a partner
and then, next, they claim Biden
somehow orchestrated
this whole thing
as a way to continue
accumulating power
as COVID subsides.
-You wonder if,
looking backward,
many years from right now,
historians will notice
the remarkable coincidence
in timing.
Have you noticed?
Here it is.
At exactly the moment
when the emergency powers
they awarded to themselves
to fight COVID started to wane,
our leaders began pushing
for conflict with Russia
and then, on the basis
of that conflict,
they assumed
historic war powers. Hm!
Virtually no one has paused
to ask him- or herself
where this might be going.
How long until our leaders
do something similar
to their domestic enemies here
in the United States?
How long before they accuse you
of collusion or disloyalty,
or some other
hard-to-define crime,
declare you an enemy
of the state,
and then confiscate
your bank account?
-[ As Carlson ]
How long before they declare you
an enemy of the state
and confiscate
your bank account?
How long until they take away
your 15% friends and family
discount at Ruby Tuesday's?
[ Laughter ]
Even though your cousin
worked there
for an entire summer.
And how long
before they tell you
you can't go
to Ruby Tuesday's anymore,
you can only go
to Ruby Monday's,
[ Laughter ]
even though it's your
constitutional right
to go to Ruby's any day
of the week?
And how long
before the waitress tells you
you can't have an Oreo shake
because that's something
that only exists at Applebee's?
[ Laughter ]
And how long after you
politely suggest
they just put Oreos
into a blender does she say,
"Can we please not have
this conversation again?"
[ Laughter ]
And after you push past her
and run to the kitchen
with the Oreos you have hidden
in your pocket,
with the full intention
of making your own,
are you wrestled to the ground
by a teenage busboy who is way
stronger than he looks?
[ Laughter ]
And how long before that busboy
looks in your eyes and says,
"I worked with your cousin.
He was a dickhead, too"?
How long?
[ Laughter ]
Of course, the reality is that
Biden has tried
to delicately thread the needle
between supporting Ukraine
and severely punishing Russia,
on the one hand;
while resisting calls
for more direct
military intervention,
on the other.
Because a direct military
conflict with Russia,
a nuclear power, could
potentially be catastrophic,
a point Biden himself made
on Friday,
in typical Biden fashion.
-We're going to continue
to stand together
with our allies in Europe
and send
the unmistakable message
that we will defend every inch
of NATO territory --
every single inch --
with the united,
galvanized NATO.
One movement.
But, look, the idea --
the idea that we're going
to send in offensive equipment
and have planes and tanks
and trains
going in with American pilots
and American crews,
just understand,
don't kid yourself.
No matter what you all say,
that's called
World War III, okay?
Let's get it straight
here, guys.
That old expression,
"Don't kid a kidder."
-[ As Biden ]
Hey, turn the mic way up
because I'm going to do
that spooky whisper thing.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, jack it way up.
I'm going to get in close.
[ Laughter ]
And what do you mean?
Are you the kidder
in this situation
and who are you trying to kid?
You sound like you're buying
a used car
at a Ford dealership
in Scranton.
[ Laughter ]
"This is a beauty.
It's a 2013 Fiesta.
It only has 300,000 miles
on it."
[ As Biden ]
Hey, pal, don't think
you could jerk my chain
like that.
[ Laughter ]
Don't kid a kidder.
Don't piss on my leg
and tell me it's raining, okay?
[ Laughter ]
Now, give me the car
for five bucks and a handshake
and we'll call it even.
[ Laughter ]
Biden is right --
the situation in Ukraine
is a humanitarian emergency
and we should do everything
possible to support Ukraine
and help the millions of people
who are suffering,
but any direct military conflict
with Russia
would threaten to quickly spiral
out of control
into a world war
between nuclear powers,
and no one wants that.
I mean,
am I the only person here
who grew up [bleep] terrified
of nuclear war?
What else is coming back
from the '80s, He-Man?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it is? Alright, sweet.
The point is Biden is right,
which is why
politicians and the media need
to be extremely careful
when discussing forms
of escalation that sound good,
but would actually be
extremely bad,
like, for example,
a no-fly zone.
If NATO and the U.S. declare
a no-fly zone over Ukraine,
we would then have to enforce it
by shooting down Russian planes,
at which point we'd be in a war
with a nuclear power.
And, when you explain that
to people,
it suddenly becomes
much less appealing,
as CBS discovered in a new poll
over the weekend.
-A new CBS News poll shows
59% of Americans support
a no-fly zone,
though the support drops to 38%
when Americans consider that it
could be taken as an act of war.
-That's right,
support for a no-fly zone drops
by over 20 points, once people
actually understand what it is.
It's like conducting a poll
where you ask people...
[ Laughter ]
And then you follow
with a second poll, ask them...
[ Laughter ]
"Free chicken nugget!
Don't finish! Hold on!
Dude, good news!
What's the second part?"
[ Laughter ]
I think it goes without saying
that this is
a very precarious moment
in which reckless
military escalation
could lead
to even more catastrophe.
We need to help the millions
of people who are suffering
and support diplomatic paths
toward an end to the conflict.
Even Ukraine's president
has said the only way
to end the war is
through dialogue.
The last thing we need right now
is, say, I don't know,
a former president
bragging that,
if he were still in office,
he would threaten
to use nuclear weapons and --
Wait. Oh, why am I positing such
an insane hypothetical?
Oh, [bleep]
We have a Trump clip coming up,
don't we? Damn it!
[ Laughter ]
-I would've done it
a lot differently
than they've done it.
And what they've done is
just terrible,
back and forth
between the United States.
Look, Biden,
every time he gets up,
he says they are
a nuclear nation.
He should say,
"We are a nuclear nation."
And, you know, I rebuilt
our whole nuclear arsenal
[ Laughter ]
stronger, bigger, better,
than ever before.
It's better and it's bigger
than Russia.
[ Laughter ]
He could say,
"We are a nuclear nation
and we don't want war
and we don't want
to wipe out anything to do
to wipe out Russia."
This is the way
he should be talking.
-First of all, don't ever feel
the need to preface any
of your remarks with,
"I would've done it
a lot differently
than they have done it."
[ Laughter ]
That's what we call,
in the math game,
a given.
[ Laughter ]
Everybody knows
we're a nuclear nation.
Is this one of those things
that Trump just found out
and he thinks he's the only one
who knows?
[ As Trump ]
You know, the U.S. is
a nuclear nation.
[ Laughter ]
Not many people know that.
Also, people don't know
Lincoln was a Republican
and that's why
he wore the big hat.
[ Laughter ]
There was a tiny nuclear missile
in there,
ready to go at any time.
[ Laughter ]
The top of the hat would open up
and then it would come right --
It was terrifying to see.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, I don't ever want
to hear any president,
current or former,
use the words wipe out,
unless they're on the TV show,
[ Laughter ]
in which case,
[bleep] go for it.
That would be am--
I would give anything
to see Trump on "Wipeout."
[ Laughter ]
And, honestly,
there's a decent chance
it happens,
if he thinks his base
would enjoy it.
Can you imagine?
Can you imagine him trying
to navigate one
of those obstacle courses?
I'm guessing Trump jumps like
a 1980s video game character.
[ Laughter ]
[ Splash ]
[ Powerdown ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
We all saw it together
for the first time.
[ Laughter ]
Russia's horrific invasion
of Ukraine
has created a dire
humanitarian disaster
and we should be
doing everything possible
to support Ukraine,
help the millions of people
who are suffering,
and find a diplomatic end
to the conflict.
The last thing we need are
more reckless threats
of escalation
from morons like Trump.
I doubt he could even find
Ukraine, or Russia, on a map.
Hell, he probably
can't even find...
-Minnesota, Wisconsin,
[ Laughter ]
Michigan,
Pennsylvania.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.